All right, you really have to see this Fox News is
making another attempt at a so-called comedy show
and I say another attempt. Many of you may not
remember this because back in 2007, Fox News
tried doing a comedy show at the time to rival Jon
Stewart on The Daily Show, sort of like right wing
Daily Show. And it was called The Half Hour News
Hour. It lasted only 17 episodes. And it was the
least funny thing that you could imagine. Fox News
is trying it again. Host Greg Gutfeld has gotten
I guess it's a promotion from a weekend
only show to a weeknight show on Fox News.
Fox News has been buying billboards trying
to put this show kind of in competition with
Stephen Colbert and Jimmy Fallon and that type of
thing. And the first episode premiered last night.
It is completely humiliating. I looked at a
bunch of clips which I'm going to play for you.
I don't know how you could make this show less
funny. Now, Greg Gutfeld, I've interacted with
Greg, got Greg Gutfeld on Twitter. The
last time we talked about Greg Gutfeld,
he tweeted about how he didn't like the clip.
I know he may see this. Listen, Greg, I'm sorry
the show's not funny. I'm not saying it's you.
Maybe it's the writers. This show is what the
kids would call Gigha cringe. Let's look at the
first clip. Even like the live studio audience
sounds not like fake, but sort of like they
don't even really understand comedy. I don't
even know how to explain it. But let's look at the
opening moments from Greg Gutfeld first episode.
All right, here we are again, a
brand new show and a brand new Greg,
I'm as giddy as Kamala Harris
explaining kids in cages.
Now, genuine question is mispronouncing Comilla
as Kamala part of the comedy in some way?
Is that a joke or does Gutfeld still not know
how to say the name of the vice president?
I can't tell what's part of the joke and that I'm
going to get back to that because I think that
may be why right wing satire doesn't work. Then
Gutfeld goes into Joe Biden dimentia material.
If you love the five and felt the need for
more JGI, that's awesome. If you ended up here
because you thought your TV was the microwave
oven. It's good to see you, Mr. President.
Your pizza will be warm in two minutes,
and Hunter, he brought the extra cheese.
Here he is. Here he is rehashing the old Brian
Williams story from I don't even know how many
years ago at this point, I guess. Would
you call this a skit? I don't even know
what this is. It's painful to watch.
It's cringe worthy to listen to you
all made a great choice for proof over at MSNBC.
Let's see what Brian Williams is up to right now.
Good evening. I'm Brian Williams and I
am on Mars. Yes, I jumped on a chopper and now
I'm on Mars. I've been here for a year now.
I built a castle here made of mastodon
carcasses and marshmallows. This is where
I invented all the covid vaccines as well as
penicillin, the smart phone and Fluffernutter.
Some things never change.
Meanwhile, what's on CNN?
You, sir, are racist and you
of racist white male, a race of
the race.
That's from the Don Lemon hour.
I mean, just painful, painful to watch. And
again, is it bad writing? Is it bad delivery?
Is it that the material just isn't funny? The
left has done satire of of some of this stuff.
You know, the Brian Williams thing. And it can be
funny. I don't know. Here's another clip. Gutfeld
taking on the Major League Baseball controversy.
So screw you. Maybe your stupid exhibition game
is about as entertaining as a magic cornhole on
ESPN at 3:00 a.m. in the morning. And screw Delta
and screw Coke. In fact, screw all corporations.
You stupid execs are cowards and bad golfers. You
cheat on your taxes and you cheat on each other.
OK, so you get the picture. I think there's a
valuable academic study to be done here. Is
there something about the right simply being
unable to do comedy? Like what's the problem in
this show? Is it bad writing? Yeah, the writing is
bad. Like even if you give that same stuff to Jon
Stewart, I don't know that Jon Stewart can make it
funny. The writing is terrible. Is it that Greg
Gutfeld can't deliver the jokes? In a funny way,
he's not delivering them in a funny way. So maybe
part of the problem is, is the host. But there's
an intangible there's like a gene is secure that
makes so-called right wing comedy and satire just
completely unfunny. I think two problems are the
rights takes on just about every issue are so dumb
that when they do jokes and satire, you kind of
can't tell, like, what's the difference between
this and when? Trump says under Joe Biden, there
will be no heat, air conditioning and you'll have
to flush your toilet 10 to 15 times. It's equally
stupid. And it either all might be a joke or it
all might be serious. And because you can't tell,
it's part of what makes this very unfunny. And
then in addition to that, I don't think right
wingers understand satire. So then the live
audience is sort of like they're clapping, I
guess, because they hear people laughing. It's
they don't even really seem to get it. And
that's part of what made the half hour news
hour so disastrous 14 years ago. You might
remember the first time I was on with Joe Rogan.
He explained to me that Steven Crowder does a
comedy show. Steven Crowder is a right wing.
Personality and Joe Rogan said, well, Steven
Crowder does comedy, and I pretended to have no
idea like I was joking, I know that in Crowder's
mind, ostensibly the Crowder show is a comedic
show. But the point was like, how can you even
really tell? It's not really funny and the jokes
are not any different than the positions
that many right wingers actually stake out.
So this is just really strange stuff. Good luck
to Greg Gutfeld. I don't know how long this one
is going to last. Maybe, you know, I think a
half hour news hour was a weekly show. So 17
I think 17 episodes is like 17 weeks. I
believe Gutfeld is doing this daily. So
17 episodes would only be like three and a half
weeks. The only funny thing about the show is
how bad the show is. And I would say check it
out for yourselves. You probably don't need to,
but we'll be monitoring it as we do right wing
media and we'll see what comes of it and we'll
see if its fate is to last more than 17 episodes
or not. We might know within the next month or so